Making the entire Web faster is a big challenge.
And although Google is a major player in the Internet,...
...it cannot move the entire Internet on its own.
We all collectively have to work together.
And Google is very interested in helping move those initiatives forward.
Helping software developers write applications that are faster.
Helping ISPs understand what's limiting their networks.
We also plan to work with standards for these...
...to make the Web protocols more speed-friendly than what they are today.
If we could come up with changes,...
...enhancements or even alternatives to TCP/IP or HTTP.
You know, that might have a significant impact.
And we'll have to advocate for it.
We'll have to explain, talk about, educate users, educate other companies...
...and work towards it.
So this will be a series of difficult advocacy steps over a long period of time.